[Music]
well first of all good to see you again
excited the premier before and if you
were after this movie and I got to tell
you do you feel change I feel a little
bit change before watching solo and
afterwards I mean a little bit I mean
here's a Star Wars movie with no Jedi's
and no force and it still it completely
held its own I mean it's it's that's
wild man won't even thought about that
that's a big deal it's a big deal which
is like for you to be in there to hear
the audience I mean we were all freaking
out it was so good I mean I was one of
the audience there's so much of the film
that I hadn't seen because it's an
ensemble piece so you know there's loads
of scenes that I mean not in and you
know characters that I don't play with
and but there was such an amazing
camaraderie on the set and in the makeup
trailer we'd all cross over and you know
just be with each other and because one
of the beautiful things about a
franchise like this is all the actors
involved you're not the stars it's the
legacy of Star Wars that's the star and
we're all little kids reduced or
enhanced to our place of innocence and
Wonder and awe and that was the feeling
when I first found out that you know
they wanted me to be to be bette to be
Val was just I went back to being six
years old the age I was when I first saw
the original style was moving listen
you've been involved in a lot of cool
projects and you've been in the business
a long time and your kids have probably
seen you do all sorts of things but how
did your stock as a mom go up when you
when they found out that you were gonna
be part of Star Wars for something so
funny there's nothing I'm so
embarrassing to my children they
honestly everything I do opening my
mouth breathing you know they're at that
age
and I remember when I found out you know
was gonna do it and I've spoken to the
directors and it was in the bag I waited
like two days before telling my kids I
was just relishing the feeling of real
because I just knew and I did it was
rotten it was like gonna be that moment
we were just like hanging out having
dinner together just cutting up food
that mummys made
oh yeah by the way guys mommy's gonna be
in the new Star Wars was just like the
silence at the table for a second it was
holy it held there for him it was holy
and I knew it would be it was so great
but the truth is it's been something
that all the kids have already enjoyed
my friend my kids because the set was a
place where the kids could come and my
four-year-old who's at he was three at
the time came on set the first day I
went on set I was with my mother it says
three generations of us and he was he
didn't even know anything about Star
Wars he's too little he's only just
talking sure and he saw something across
the set his enormous set that was like
you know a country and he saw something
I just saw him I saw him noticed
something and I look to where he was
looking and it was r2d2 and he just
walked over away from mommy and all of
us to this this shape and then the guy
that was doing the remote control for
r2d2 saw my son and started to actually
make a juice box make our to talk to
Booker so book I had a conversation for
like two minutes and he ended up giving
our duty to a hug and we were all just
standing back like tears in my eyes
and that was my son's first impression
of r2d2 not a doll not in the movies but
like lives and he's gonna be like sup
man yeah right you gotta like bring it
now because I've had serious like where
do you go from here as a mom I guess you
know potentially more solo I think I've
reached the zenith I think I you know
it's pretty special
okay well for a lot of people we talked
a little bit about the fans of this
franchise have you had any really
memorable fan encounters from this
specific project yet as it has it kind
of I don't know as it landed on them
that you're part of this and is affected
that's like a heat heat coming from
somewhere this just this buzzing you
know whether it's on social media or
just you know anywhere and it's a really
warm good sensation excite
and it's full of just a kind of positive
energy because that's the love for this
these characters and this whole world
and it's a world of hope and it's a
place of escapism but also with you know
projections into the future of what we
could be dealing with you know it's it's
a really exciting it's really exciting
to be a part of it and particularly this
movie because you know Han is such a
rebellious devil-may-care he's the kid
that gets into trouble and does the
things that every other kid wishes they
could you know they could have done and
he's just this gorgeous young you know
rookie who's just got nothing to lose
because you know everything's gone from
him for him and you know for him to go
on this adventure and this journey you
know to become the Harrison Ford
character that we all know and love but
just I just feel like it's such a move
great movie for our time because it's
about hope and it's about jumping all in
and having faith that's something bigger
than you is gonna catch you know and
it's that's the energy of this I think
we're all in that place right now of
like we're in this well but you know
crazy crazy time so I feel like this
energy is gonna be just soaked in by the
audience I'm so excited
all been stepping into those shoes into
the Han Solo shoes how did he do how did
he do how did he do it is like
unparalleled this actor I was I would
come and go as we all did because it was
an ensemble cast but he obviously was
the thread that you know just carried
everything through I think he had one
day off in a year literally he just his
commitment his his stamina he's he's
kind of calm in the storm because there
was there was so much anticipation there
was so many you know people and elements
that were relying on this to really
deliver because this is a character that
people love so much and it's really
going to define a moment in in the
legacy of Star Wars and he just was
kind of Zen energy through the whole
thing and I think like the premier he
was kind of like that but I was saying
to him I said listen honey are you okay
because you went through so much for
this and I can't think of anything that
could match what he gave to the movie no
premiere no number of fans this guy gave
all of himself and he was like yeah I
think you know I feel good and that was
just all I needed to hear
we know we got to spend some time with
Harrison Ford did you get a chance to
meet Harrison not in this not in this
world but oh god I can't wait to hear
what he thinks you mentioned having
family on set and Aldens oh nana was
there and she kind of spilled the beans
about his about his involvement and you
know even despite the fact that he had
an NDA agreement how did did anything
similar with your family visiting said
was anything anything kind of leaked or
did you have to do they have to sign
NDA's like you're 40 I mean how does it
all work the secrecy is part of what's
delicious about it all you know it's
part of the fun it's part of the
Brotherhood like the sisterhood rather
or both it's it's it's you invest and
it's it's it's nice I love delayed
gratification myself I love building up
the excitement before you know getting
you know earning that treat and that's
what I feel like waiting and not knowing
is all about and we do spoil it for
ourselves that's why they're called
spoilers you know smashing squealing
some things but you know I get that too
people want to know because it's too
much excitement they need to kind of you
know water it down but you know I come
from a time being so old and everything
where I would wait a whole week to watch
Dallas with my mom on a Wednesday night
and know literally like Monday would
come around it's coming Tuesday and I
would enjoy and you know each week you'd
kind of I don't know there's something
about waiting for something special that
is so is so rewarding so it's not cruel
thing not to let everybody know about it
and my kids just loved it they loved the
fact that they had a little secret that
they couldn't even tell their friends
literally they couldn't even tell their
friends about mom
that's incredible and I got her up
things up but last question really quick
we know that Ron's daughter Brice
visited the set a little bit any other
famous faces that came to the set just
to kind of witness this incredible
friendship so many wanted to just come
by and visit oh my goodness I can't even
I can't even well me literally like
you're right here at Pinewood okay right
and there's Jurassic world's shooting
over there my daughter was shooting with
Tim Burton in DUMBO over there I mean I
would literally meet my kid for lunch
she was the starring this Newton Burton
movie was coming out next year she was
so crazy meeting my kid for lunch in the
cafeteria that isn't she and her Dumbo
costume me like shrouded in mummies Star
Wars costume I should have taken
pictures of that being on that day so
yeah I mean we had I can't even think of
what a mother-daughter moment you
shooting Star Wars you're shooting Tim
Burton big that's incredible good for
you good for her and your whole family
this is so exciting I gotta I have to
let you go but congratulations that is a
great job thanks really great you're on
[Music]